so there's been a burst of energy and
interfaith cooperation over the past 10
or 15 years it's partially a result of
society is becoming more religiously
diverse it's partially a result of high
profiled religious extremism and
religious conflict a lot of energy in a
field is good but I think what's even
better are models of effectiveness and
part of what what we've done at
Interfaith youth core has identified a
model of effectiveness and interfaith
cooperation that we call the Interfaith
triangle the resize of that triangle our
attitudes relationships and knowledge
and what we need to be doing in
interfaith programs is making sure that
we're facilitating positive meaningful
relationships between people from
different faith backgrounds advancing
appreciative knowledge and we know based
on social science data that that
improves people's attitudes so scaling
that model of effectiveness that
interfaith triangle across the variety
of interfaith programs that are popping
up on college campuses and in cities
across America in the world I think is
really important to improving this field
you